you
hi everyone is Jerry this is a game from
Round four
seventy-fifth taught to steal chess
tournament between Levon Aronian who's
playing the white side against the
current world champion fishing on to
have a look at this twenty three move
encounter one that is certainly filled
with one tactical blow after another
very very sharp stuff very dynamic play
goes on and that will often spring about
depending on the type of opening or the
type of variation of an opening and in
this game we have the semi Slav and to
be more exact the mirror and variation
of the semi Slav denoted by this Bishop
d3 move and then D takes c4 so stuff
that has all been seen many times before
black is expanding on the Queen side to
facilitate the queen bishops development
the bishop reacts to put pressure on h7
black does similar on the corresponding
h2 square both sides castle and after
Queen c2 we have pressure on both h7 and
the Queen looks to try and prevent this
c5 advance ideally this is the type of
break black would like to be getting in
this pawn as a stand is just backwards
and a liability
Bishop b7 a3 the Queen rook gets working
and now Knight g5 again stuff we have
seen all before where 12 moves in and
we're just about another 12 away from
the game ending after Knight g5 there's
pressure against h7 that's the thing
that is crying out at this point it's
hit three times and it's defended twice
so what do you do about it
well anon doesn't do a thing about it
instead he strikes at the center with c5
and says let's open the position up at a
moment we're on the side that is better
developed let's open the position up at
a moment where your Queen side pieces
are not doing a thing and I'm offering
upon for it it's something that white
goes in for we do end up having Knight
takes h7 but before I get into that I do
want to point out well I will be
pointing out many variations throughout
this video and this is one of them there
is the potential for black to grab on h2
and then follow up with Knight g4 and
then grab the knight and after the smoke
clears black is up upon but do know that
if you're the black side and you're
going in for this that white has
compensation in the form of
what in the form of pawn structure and
in the form of well still having the
bishop pair okay so something to
certainly be aware of and I believe that
white is going to be the favorable side
I think it's certainly worth upon to
have those two factors the bishop pair
and the pawn structure but we don't have
that we don't have a bishop takes h2 we
have c5 and well I'll take your pick you
have the bishop
you have the knight let's look at the
bishop it's not what happens in the game
but these what ifs are very very
important it's something that both
players are certainly having to think
about of course the bishop couldn't have
been taken because we'd end up just
having made on h7 so a couple variations
that could follow up from here this one
right here after h4 we could have Queen
to b6 and white is just getting all
their pieces working with this last move
they're fully developed pressure on the
center I could try to hold it together
it spawned by the way now on d4 is
isolated all pieces are working this
rook will not all pieces all but this
rook right here the bishops on adjacent
diagonals Queen putting pressure on the
center and it seems like things are just
held together by a thread on the white
side both Knight and Queen as it stands
right now are having to babysit the
bishop I'm at age 7 square so there's
certainly in short compensation for
black being down upon if that position
were to come about one additional line
that I'd like to run by you is one that
is certainly less than optimal but the
reason I'm going to go forward with this
particular line right now is to
emphasize the fact that bishops that are
on adjacent diagonals are very very
powerful and I believe that this is
highlighted in the following variation
one where it might be tempting to just
go ahead and grab this pond and have
ideas of swinging over laterally but
things can happen much more quickly for
team white
excuse me team black by just ripping
into the white position grabbing on h2
with one Bishop being sacrificed and
just to move later
another one a double Bishop sacrifice
and the king is stripped of all
defenders and this king is running for
his life and there's just no hope after
this rook up and then soon enough over
so again just to emphasize the bishops
and their strength when they work on
diagonals that are right next to one
another we do not in this game have
bishop takes on h7 but rather Knight
takes h7 Black has ignored the pawn on
h7 and similarly is ignoring the
pressure on the rook by playing Knight
to g4 instead focusing the attention on
this h2 square there is of course no
time to grab the rook because of check
and then this is going to be deadly no
escape from here so we would not have
that there are some other ways of
defending in the game we saw f4 but
before I get to that lets rule out
something crazy and by crazy I mean g3
putting the King into a position where
he has no legal moves Knight takes h2 is
yet another position or another
variation that is highlighting the
strength of these two guys these two
bishops King takes Queen comes out
exploiting the pin King moves game over
not the way to go g3 is terrible h3 is a
possibility however after Bishop h2 king
h1 Queen h4 well blacks is down the pond
but what what is where is the
compensation well it involves having all
pieces now working the threat here is
Queen takes h3 exploiting the fact that
this pawn on g2 is pinned is something
like d5 well now we could just have the
rook reacting to the knight's threat all
pieces are working for black not all
pieces are working for white and this is
a very very dangerous position for white
if there is a save it's maybe something
that a computer could be coming up with
but it's very very difficult for a human
to find all accurate moves if you're
playing on the white side so that's a
not a variation we're getting into
instead we saw after Knight g4 f4 to
defend against h2 position opens up in
the center capturing on D and we have
the immediate recapture
if white is being materialistic grabbing
out FA the bishop recaptures and after
this night on D to f6 move surprisingly
enough there is no good solution to the
Queen just grabbing the pon centralizing
yourself and delivering a check what can
be done in this position here if
something like h3 to chase the night
away well we could just be having the
Queen grabbing on d4 and this position
is so strong for black that they can
afford the exchange of Queens allow this
Knight to be captured I'll just show
this line right here that runs rook d8
grab the knight have the Queen's come
off and this rook is still a very very
powerful piece the potential to play to
h3 and some lines exploiting the pin if
fruit d1 g3 pressure on g4 g2 Knight g4
stuff the bishop ready to come back to
being on an adjacent diagonal there's
not really going to be a good solution
in this position for white there's still
a lot of pressure - the Queen's in this
position for black so we don't have that
instead what we do have well we don't
have excuse me you don't have Knight
takes rook but rather just the immediate
recapture on d4 and now comes another
shocking move we have if you'd like to
try and figure it out now be the time to
pause the video for Team black we have
the move Bishop c5 crazy crazy stuff
okay this pawn is in a pin but the
question that cries out to you is just
okay why not grab the bishop so let's
cover that first if the bishop is taking
Knight takes pawn this Bishop is hit
twice this Queen is also just eyeing
that d4 square with check potential for
Knight tricks on this f2 square if white
is insisting on just material grabs with
that rook on f8 we could have the check
at the very least with this variation
that I'm now showing at the very least
black is getting their material back and
still has a stronger position Queen in a
good position on d4 centralized
this queen is in an uncomfortable pin or
excuse me this Knight is in an
uncomfortable pin and these guys the
queenside pieces remain as spectators so
that's a reason to maybe not be going
forward with this capture of the bishop
and well what's one other possibility
one other possibility might be the
knight coming back to g5 but this is
something that LaVon discounted this is
something that he had spoke about in the
postgame he discounted this just because
of the immediate recapture of the
material and then or excuse me the
balancing out of the material and then
after Knight d2 f6 black is just the
side that stands better has a nice plus
so we're not having that either we're
not having Knight to g5 in this case
instead we had the move Bishop to e2 one
other this and look looking at the
clocks here there isn't about an hour
and 31 minutes that LaVon had he ended
up playing that Bishop to e2 move it
took a good 50 minutes of thought for
him to come up with that that move
Bishop to e2 but one other variation
that I do want to draw your attention to
is one that runs after the capture on
this square and the knight recapture I
was just I was just showing you this
Knight takes rook variation but if the
knight comes back to g5 this one I want
to show because it draws attention to a
very classic game one that's known as
Rubenstein's immortal and if you're
familiar with that particular game
you'll see what I talk about or what
what I'm talking about when you see the
potential lateral movement of an ensuing
rook here on c8 so if the knight drops
back to g5 I'm going with this
particular line because its intention is
to try and cover this f2 square after
Queen d4 King here Knight takes bishop
let's say the knight drops back to h3
just to defend on f2 I'm not saying in
any way that this is the best variation
or the best
Fenster light but again just to
highlight how similar this game is to
that classic Rubenstein's immortal where
he's playing the black side against
George rotli we we could have Knight
takes b2 with the idea here being if
Bishop takes Knight
well the knight would just come in with
great effect hitting everything Queen
rook pawn on g2 this is going to be game
over for for white quickly and the other
line would run Queen takes B and now
rook takes nine and if white is thinking
that they could try and get the Queens
off and be saved with the Bishop to d2
they're sadly mistaken and this is where
in my mind at least that game was
highlighted the Rubenstein's immortal
where the rook can actually swing over
laterally capture the knight offer the
Queen and now we're going to end up
delivering mate to this white King in a
very forceful way all with Czech rook
takes H rook takes G with Czech rook
comes back over to H with double check
and then finally mate on each one so an
interesting sequence of moves that I
came up with when I was reviewing for
this game if the knight was coming back
here to try and defend against that f2
square not the case in this game what we
did have after Bishop c5 was the Bishop
e2 move one that took about 50 minutes
by Aronian and now another shocking move
namely Knight dd5 crazy crazy stuff
allowing the bishop to still be captured
it seems like this Knight can maybe be
captured
if pawn takes Bishop in this case we're
just going to be having what we're going
to be having the Queen check we're going
to have the King go in the corner Knight
F to check if the King goes here we have
the very common smothered mate happening
and so the other option of course is to
just be taking this night when a place
to f2 but now with this Queen on f2
there's not only the threat of capturing
on g2 to deliver mate but also there's
some issues on the back rank this rook
is not doing a thing just yet so there
is just no good to
at this point to both Queen takes g2 and
the Queen making use of the back rank by
way of e1 first so we wouldn't have
Bishop takes nine here's another one
that is really cool what would you do as
black if pawn takes Knight and this is
really for those of you who happen to be
subscribers of mine on the chest network
YouTube channel because this is a video
that I want
I covered specifically this combination
right here on December 31st 2012 can you
spot the winning continuation for Team
black in this position now would be the
time to pause the video continuation is
Queen takes d4 that video was titled a
variant of a very famous chess
combination that chess combination being
a smothered mate and sure enough we have
a slight variation one that involves
having a queen bishop battery and then
delivering a smothered mate on f2 very
very cool stuff it's bringing about in
this game here in the seventy-fifth top
2 steel tournament we do not have the
knight being captured and that is the
reason why what we do have instead is
Bishop takes Knight and now first Bishop
takes d4 with check King goes to the
corner and now Knight takes g4 the
threat here being just to get this last
piece working the bishop on b7 the
bishop on d4 still on their adjacent
diagonals this is going to be lights out
for white there's not going to be a good
defense so let's see how things finish
up Knight takes rook and it might be
very tempting to just want to come out
right away because what do you do about
the defense of this pawn if you move it
well that's just going to be main but
you have to be very exact if you bring
the Queen out right away there's going
to be a save in that of Queen h7 the
Queen's come off and white is saved so
how do you defend against that amidst
all of this all these complications all
these uh Bishop Bishop moves to c5 this
Knight jumping into
five in the middle of it all what do we
have we have f5 this is the in my
opinion the coolest move of the game
I like these uh these bishop moves and
this this Knight move and all these
different mating combinations but to see
this little column move this quiet move
that just has the intention of
interfering with the knight in Queens
communication of this h7 square and then
bringing the Queen out one move later I
just think is really really cool stuff I
like seeing that that sort of uh those
sort of moves play what a great shot
right there f5 and well really at this
point there's just not going to be a
defense it's just a matter of finishing
white off at this point what is tried in
the game is Knight g6 defending against
Queen h4 Queen f6 just ready to grab
that night and now H h3 trying to kick
the night away but he doesn't have to go
anywhere instead just Queen takes Knight
Queen to e2 is what was tried queen h5
keep in mind the knight is immune from
capture this is just going to be me
black is controlling that G 1 square so
the Queen grabs this Knight if the
knight is running away
if he goes instead of h3 in this case if
he goes to e5 you just sacrifice an h2
similarly if the King takes the knight
Queen h4 that's going to be lights out
so we don't have Knight to e5 it is
instead h3 the Queen grabs the night and
now Queen e2 Queen h5 the threat here is
to just grab on h3 and that's just game
over once again exploiting this pin on
the g2 pond so what's tried is Queen to
d3 but after Bishop to e3 an
interference move light is forced to
resign there's not a good thing to be
doing at this point if Bishop takes
Bishop Queen takes pawn with check
followed by mate on g2 and if Queen
takes bishop well we're just still
grabbing the Queen
and yet again this is just leading to
made on g2 there is one other variation
that could have come about in this this
ending position after Queen h5 instead
of Queen d3 if rook f3 Knight f2 check
if the if the knight is captured this is
going to lead to a mate and to yet again
Queen takes h3 exploiting the pin and
exploiting yet another pin all all in
part 2 these bishops being on adjacent
diagonals so we wouldn't have rook takes
Knight in this case instead it would be
the King just moving to h2 but now comes
Bishop takes rook this is a position
where the Queen's are off the board but
black is certainly decide that is just
much much better this Bishop is he stuck
this pressure on the Queen side there's
not a good solution for why even in this
more simplified endgame if the knight is
grabbing a pond you could always give a
check and well this position is so
strong the bishop could back up and now
there's no way this Bishop has been a
spectator has not moved for the whole
game nor has this rook and he will soon
be falling from this position here
there's just no good solution however
you slice it and in this game the final
move the final column move here this
interference move was Bishop to e3 and
again Aronian was just forced to resign
so what a game by Anand it's a really
really exciting stuff and I hope you
enjoyed it so that's all for this video
I hope you got something out of it take
care bye